demasiada presión sobre sus hombros la
estrella de 15 años camila valjevo
terminó en llanto tras su accidentada
presentación de este jueves en la final
individual de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno era la gran favorita algo que
pareció recriminarle su entrenadora
porque lo dejaste ir le preguntó tras
una actuación en la que terminó cuarta
esa reacción fría instante de éter y tú
vérettes y puso una vez más el caso de
valjevo en el ojo del huracán ahora no
sólo por el positivo por dopaje que ha
marcado su presencia en beijing 2022
me quedé muy perturbado ayer cuando vi
la competencia en televisión
y después la forma en la que fue
recibida por su entorno al salir del
hielo es escalofriante se sentía la
distancia como se puede ser tan frío con
su deportista el propio back insistió en
ese contexto en que el comité está
debatiendo si modifica la edad mínima de
participación para las competiciones
senior algo que también abordará la
unión internacional de patinaje sobre
hielo a esto respondió el kremlin que ya
en el pasado ha expresado su respaldo a
valiera en medio de su positivo no le
gusta la dureza entrenadores pero todo
el mundo sabe que en los deportes de
élite la dureza del entrenador es la
clave de las victorias de los alumnos en
moscú el apoyo a la patinadora se
muestra masivo con pancartas en las que
se lee camila estamos contigo aunque el
tribunal de arbitraje deportivo permitió
a valiyev a continuar con su
participación pese a su positivo el caso
se sigue investigando en el horizonte
una posible sanción que le arrebate a la
joven la medalla de oro que ganó en la
prueba por equipos lo que tal vez deje
en pedazos a la talentosa patinadora del
hielo